Film Courage: When we tell a story, we’re
entering into a contract with the audience?
Adam Skelter, writer, director, story artist:
Yes, from the video [referring to Adam’s
Youtube channel The Art Of Story].
Film Courage: Can we talk about that?
What’s the contract?
Can we get out of the contract?
Adam Skelter: Sure…you pay a price for it.
So basically when you sit down and say “I’m
going to tell you a story,” you are promising
something.
And in the video, I draw the comparison, I
use the metaphor of you’re taking out a
loan from somebody and what you’re promising
is that you’re going to pay it back and
that they will get the interest for their
investment of attention and attention is the
currency that they are spending.
It’s actually probably the most important
currency (like real-world currency) that we’re
dealing with is the currency of attention,
especially with the Internet, especially with
the entertainment industry.
Literally entertainment is the industry of
getting people to pay attention.
So what you’re doing, if you’re promising
that it’s going to be worth it, there’s
going to be worth putting their time into
it.
Your job as the artist is not only to present
conflict in an interesting way but to make
it mean something to them and that’s where
it gets very subjective.
That’s why you can have some of the great
storytelling and only a few people will get
it because it’s relative to like whatever
psychological dynamics or whatever value is
resonate with them.
Film Courage: Can you give me an example of
a story that does pay off where the contract
is fulfilled and someone’s obligation is
paid off and then maybe one that is not fulfilled?
Adam Skelter: Hmmm…a ton.
What’s a good simple one?
BACK TO THE FUTURE…will he get back to the
future?
Right there you are making a promise with
that title.
Usually the contract you are making with the
audience is right in the title, it’s right
in the trailer.
Will he get back to the future?
You’re promising in some way not only are
you going to answer the question, but that
you’re going to enjoy the ride and then
it’s going to mean something when he gets
there and I do think that ultimately he goes
through this whole journey.
It’s Michael J. Fox who’s endlessly entertaining
and then was it Zemeckis [writer/director]?
Who is just brilliant, like it’s perfectly
directed, it’s so much fun and it’s the
movie that everybody has seen so I would always
use it as like the perfect example of just
an entertaining movie.
It’s just a completely entertaining movie.
I think it completely fulfilled the contract.
You’re entertained the entire time and then
in the end he gives you exactly what you want
in a way you don’t expect and it’s fun,
you enjoyed it.
But along the way you’re also learning little
themes like about this high school teenager
who’s learning to appreciate his family
and learning what his parents went through
and stuff like that, that actually resonates
on kind of a more subconscious level.
He begins to develop an appreciation for the
different generations and then how that story
continues on in his own life.
Film Courage: He’s almost reliving his Dad’s
experience in some sense.
He’s becoming like…his Dad was not the
most popular guy in high school and was bullied
and then he’s experiencing it himself because
he [Marty McFly] stands up to Biff.
Adam Skelter: Then another example (which
I think is actually a really interesting example),
look at NO COUNTRY FOR OLD MEN.
Now the thing I love about The Coen Brothers
is that they are constantly subverting the
audience’s expectations, they’re playing
with it, they play with the contract constantly
which is where that alienates a lot of people.
But the people who are willing to take the
journey with them they find something incredibly,
much more rewarding.
With NO COUNTRY FOR OLD MEN, I don’t know
if you read the novel, as well?
Film Courage: I did not.
Adam Skelter: Ohhh….I love Cormac McCarthy
[Written in 2005].
He’s one of my favorite writers.
I always compare him to if like Hemingway
and Faulkner had a baby, it would be Cormac
McCarthy.
So Llewelyn Moss [Josh Brolin’s character]
he’s kind of the hero, he’s the underdog
in the story and you’re following this whole
journey and the whole contract is, is it going
to mean something that Llewelyn Moss is going
to find this bag full of millions of dollars,
go on a journey and change his life and everything
is going to be awesome after that?
We’re going to get into spoilers here [***SPOILER
ALERT***].
Film Courage: Okay, spoiler alert.
Adam Skelter: Spoiler alert.
So when he goes to this entire journey and
in the novel they also did this as well and
he gets to the point and the sheriff Tommy
Lee Jones [as character Ed Tom Bell] is following
him around and you’re waiting for this whole
thing to build to this, explosive, climatic
payoff where it’s Anton Chigurh [played
by Javier Bardem] and they are both well-matched
and there’s this hero and this villain and
you’re waiting for the big standoff…and
it doesn’t come.
Instead Tommy Lee Jones drives up to a hotel,
he sees just barely the periphery of some
standoff and Llewelyn Moss is gone.
And we never even saw it, we just see that
he’s gone.
And immediately, when I first read it, I had
to go back and reread it…like “Did I miss
something?”
Because my first response was “I just got
cheated.”
They got me to invest in Llewelyn Moss, he’s
making this huge sacrifice, why did he do
this?
But it was the fact that he did subvert that
contract, that he did subvert our expectations
and then when you see it in the movie, they
adapted it perfectly, where it’s also, it’s
anticlimactic but it’s the fact that you’re
expecting the climax that created the meaningful
resonance afterward.
Like after that when you start looking at
‘what did it mean that Llewelyn Moss just
left and it wasn’t a standoff?’
In fact his wife ends up having to pay the
price as well.
She ends up leaving by Anton Chigurh, as well.
And ultimately it’s this question (you know
it goes back to the theme) that is this no
country for old men?
Like is this some evil that’s ancient that
has no mercy for goodness or kind people?
Ultimately it really comes down to when you’re
paying off a contract, you’re trying to
engage their attention and if you do break
it, you have to have a good reason for it.
Art is a bridge, you’re trying to build
across the waters to somebody else’s mind.
So ultimately every single artist builds their
bridges differently.
Michael Bay will build his bridge all the
way across so people can kind of step on and
have a conveyor belt across.
And then Kubrick will build this bridge halfway
across and the audience has to build their
bridge halfway across and they meet in the
middle.
And then you’ll get someone like Wim Wenders
or someone who takes you on a journey and
you don’t know where it’s going and you’re
pretty much building a bridge to where he
is at.
Everybody decides, every artist decides how
far they want to build their bridge across
the water.
Film Courage: Don’t you think though that
every writer thinks that there is a payoff
[in their movie]?
It makes sense to them, but unfortunately
to an outside view, they may not see that
payoff?
Adam Skelter: Sure.
I can’t speak for other writers.
Sure.
I do think that there is the basic economy
of story, if you promise something give it
in a way that…the old adage is give the
audience what they want in a way they don’t
expect.
But it really comes down to the needs of the
story.
What are you trying to convey with your story?
And I don’t like imposing too much…like
to me, what’s really interesting is when
finding the exception of those rules until
it actually means something new.